[Musique]
à l'occasion de la présentation des vœux
à la presse comme à chaque début d'année
le président du Département Cyril
Melchior a reçu les représentants des
rédactions de l'île ce jeudi 5 janvier
au Palais de la source entouré des vices
présidents Béatrice sigismo Augustine
Romano
Eric Ferrer et Gilbert Cyril Melchior a
salué la qualité du travail des
journalistes locaux
comme la réunion je voudrais saluer
votre travail salut la qualité de votre
engagement citoyen au service de
l'information de réunionnaise et de
Réunionnais face à
l'instantanéité de l'information la
liberté et la pluralité de la presse
sont précieuse dans un contexte de
conflit
et chacun
reçoit citoyen élu doit en être le
garant et permettre aux journalistes de
travailler de poursuivre leur métier de
messager de l'information après avoir
souhaité une année 2023 épanouissante de
santé et de bonheur aux Réunionnaises et
aux Réunionnais le président a passé en
revue les projets à réaliser pour les
années à venir 2023 sera certainement
une année aussi difficile disons Leclerc
roman c'est pour cela que nous allons
pouvoir suivre nos travaux pour
accompagner toujours les plus faibles et
plus fragiles les jeunes qui sont en
difficulté d'assiation et qui nous
convient d'accompagner mais je pense
aussi aux jeunes qui ont réussi qui ont
fait l'effort de faire des études qui se
retrouvent éloignées de la Réunion et
qui voudrait revenir travailler dans les
entreprises réunionnaises et bien nous
allons lancer un appel à projet pour
qu'il y ait un LinkedIn 97.4
c'est-à-dire un site permettant de en
connexion les entreprises les
collectivités Réunionnaises et les
jeunes Réunionnais qui n'arrivent pas à
revenir travailler dans l'île
l'accompagnement des personnes
âgées parfois porteuse d'handicap avec
l'ARS nous avons un plan qui va nous
permettre dans les prochaines années et
on va démarrer ce plan 2023 de créer
2000 places d'accueil supplémentaires
pour les personnes âgées les personnes
porteuses handicapées ce qui représente
50% de plus en capacité d'accueil et
nous voulons pour suivre le
développement et l'aménagement de l'île
à travers de l'agriculture qui va nous
permettre de tendre vers la sécurité
alimentaire agriculture aménagement de
l'île avec un niveau d'investissement de
190 millions d'euros qui nous permettent
de donner du travail aux entreprises et
donc aux salariés des mêmes entreprises
pour des travaux sur les routes dans les
collèges sur nos bâtiments au niveau de
l'irrigation par exemple sans oublier
bien évidemment le volet écologique avec
notre le plan un million d'arbres que
tout le monde connaît et le fait que
nous voulons être une collectivité à
énergie positive donc ça c'est pour le
volet investissement je ne vais pas
oublier la promotion de chaque
réunionnaise et rayonner à travers le
sport et la culture
2023 je désire de l'Australien à
Madagascar 2024 les jeux de paris Jeux
Olympiques nous allons cueillir la
flamme olympique ici et le département
veut être un acteur qui permet à toutes
les personnes qui le souhaitent va de
participer à ces événements à travers
les ligues et les comités et sur le
volet culturel nous avons fait la
proposition que le musée donc de Villèle
se transforme en musée de l'habitation
de l'esclavage parce que dans l'océan
Indien ce site n'existe pas vraiment et
nous avons à vilaine la possibilité de
réaliser donc un grand mémorial autour
de l'esclavage c'est ce que nous voulons
faire un ensemble d'actions et de
propositions ambitieuses que le
Département souhaite inscrire en faveur
d'une meilleure cohésion sociale sur le
territoire en 2023
[Musique]